i think it's important for entrepreneurs
to thank the people in their lives who
are helping make an impact who are
helping them grow their business because
it's hard doing everything yourself so
today i want to thank dane weiniger and
dan is uh how did i meet dan then i met
through facebook and he was a fan of my
stuff and and liked the content i was
creating and one day uh you know he
reached out to me and asked me to check
out his video and if i had any feedback
for him and i gave him some thoughts and
told them a few ways to to improve it
and he he took that and went right to
work and started making them better
and uh he kept being a fan and kept
looking at the content i was putting out
and said
evan i'd like you
to come and potentially speak at our
company's event our annual retreat for
all the franchisees that he's a part of
and he connected me with the founder and
we had a great session and then he
invited me to come down and i just came
back from orlando when i met dan i met
the team and it was a great experience
and what i love about dan is that he's
constantly trying to reach out to people
to find out how he can help them he's
not just selling his services right he's
not contacting me and saying hey evan
will you buy my video services right
he's looking for ways to help
so he started just by
being a fan and sharing some of my stuff
and of course that helps me and right
and if he's telling me that he likes
some of the stuff i'm creating and which
one it is that helps me
gauge you know what's working what isn't
it makes me feel good too to hear from
fans
and then he's looking for ways he can
help his fellow franchisees right so
he loved the content i was creating the
videos i was putting out and thought
that other people could benefit from it
as well and beyond just sharing the
links to the videos to have me come and
speak at their event and connect with
people one-on-one and he did that
because he genuinely wanted his other
franchisees to be better and dan makes a
habit of trying to connect people even
if has nothing to do with his business
just trying to connect people
because he realizes first that it makes
him feel good right it makes the other
person feel feels good and then it also
it helps your business if you're
spending your time helping people you're
going to stay top of mind and they're
going to look for ways to help you out
as well so then thank you so much thank
you for being a fan thank you be for
being a friend thank you for picking me
up from the airport thank you for
recommending me to the event i had a
blast meeting you and for those of you
watching i hope you'll take some time
this week to thank somebody who's had an
impact in your business somehow
and make them feel
special
believe for those of you watching like
the video consider supporting me by
clicking the link in the description
leave a comment let me know what you
think and click on my face to subscribe
to the channel thank you so much i'll
see you soon
you